un camp de fortune sous des températures
de plus en plus basses alors que des
centaines de migrants s'entassent à la
frontière en espérant passer en pologne
minsk prévient qu'elle répondra de
manière instantanée en cas d'attaqué
extérieure
on a l'impression que nos voisins
occidentaux notamment la pologne sont
prêts tout en résolvant leurs problèmes
politiques internes ainsi que leurs
relations au sein de l'union européenne
a déclenché un conflit dans lequel ils
veulent entraîner l'europe les cantons
les prêteurs que mon bureau le langage
des ultimatums des menaces et du
chantage est inacceptable les forces
armées de la république de biélorussie
sont prêtes à riposter sévèrement à
toute attaque la biélorussie avait déjà
tenté de faire pression jeudi en
menaçant de rompre l'approvisionnement
en gaz de l'europe des menaces tempéré
par son amie russe qui assure que
l'alimentation énergétique n'est pas un
moyen de pression à l'ordre du jour
varsovie a déployé 15 mille soldats à la
frontière pour empêcher les migrants de
rentrée
ces gens sont approvisionnés en bois
pour faire du feu et en os la
croix-rouge bélarus leur a aussi donné
des provisions donc on voit que les
soldats se prépare à un plus long séjour
de ces personnes à la frontière
nous avons fait face à une situation peu
courante et dangereuse les autorités
bélarusses ont visé les soldats polonais
avec des lasers verts
la situation inquiète au delà des
frontières entre les deux pays
washington n'a pas manqué de s'exprimer
c'est une source de grande inquiétude
nous avons fait part de nos
préoccupations à la russie nous avons
fait part de nos inquiétudes à la
biélorussie moscou estime qu'une issue
au problème ne dépend pas seulement de
minsk mais aussi de l'union européenne
je veux que tout le monde sache que nous
n'avons rien à voir avec ceux là ils
essaient de nous en faire porter la
responsabilité
et pour n'importe quelle raison et même
sans aucune raison ce ne sont pas nos
compagnies aériennes qui transportent
ces personnes en fait aucune de nos
entreprises ne les transporte d'ailleurs
bellavia comme l'a dit loukachenko ne
transporte pas non plus ces personnes
je tiens à souligner une fois de plus
que la russie n'a absolument rien à voir
avec cette affaire ne sommes pas du tout
impliqués dans ce processus
de leur côté les nations unies appelle
les deux parties à penser avant tout aux
migrants bloqués dans des camps de
fortune
notre message à toutes les parties et
que les gens ne doivent pas être
instrumentalisée ils ne sont pas des
pions ce sont des êtres humains en fin
de compte ce qui doit se passer c'est
que leurs besoins fondamentaux et leurs
droits fondamentaux doivent être prises
en charge selon human rights watch plus
de deux mille personnes seraient
actuellement bloqués à la frontière
l'union européenne a accusé la
biélorussie d'acheminer ces migrants aux
portes de l'europe devant ces
accusations la turquie a annoncé ce
vendredi suspendre ses vols à
destination de la biélorussie pour les
ressortissants yéménites syriens et
turcs
de son côté le royaume uni a déployé un
groupe de militaires venus prêter main
forte aux gardes-frontières